a touching tribute to the late Chadwick
Boseman that's also a thrilling new
installment in the MCU Saga black
panther wakanda forever was a tall order
but Marvel Studios pulled it off here's
how
wakanda forever is the 30th feature film
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe by now
audiences are so familiar with the mcu's
opening credits format we could all
probably reproduce the moving letters
and rousing music from memory but Marvel
has been experimenting with its
recognizable logo as of late the titles
for Thor love and thunder swapped the
traditional MCU soundtrack for a guns
and roses-esque power ballad version and
werewolf By Night bypassed them all
together for its own short Snappy and
brightly colored introduction but Marvel
Studios opening credits have never
looked or sounded like they do in
wakanda forever and they've never been
used for such a purpose before the
standard sequencies hand-drawn Marvel
Comics illustrations morph into live
action Marvel Studios film clips all on
the surface of 3D block letters as each
new superhero is introduced they get
added to the next entries Graphics but
this time rather than the entire stable
of Marvel superheroes being represented
every still and clip is of Chadwick
Boseman as t'challa for the first time
there's no music underscoring the
visuals it's 30 seconds of respectful
silence as the words Marvel Studios fix
themselves in the center of the screen
they briefly glow purple the shade of
the heart-shaped herb before Fading Into
the silver and black of t'challa's black
panther suit there's nothing especially
deep about superficial changes to a
corporate logo but they help to set the
tone for the film that's about to unfold
Bozeman's tragic death in August of 2020
meant that black panther wakanda forever
had to be Rewritten from a script that
was already in the works fans and
filmmakers alike debated about the best
way forward for the franchise given the
choice between recasting the main
character or elevating the status of one
of the supporting players director and
co-writer Ryan coogler opted for the
latter and got to work retooling the
script the movie opens with a
heart-wrenching scene in which shuri is
racing against the clock to improve the
formula for her synthetic heart-shaped
her but before she can test out the
unlikely cure her mother Queen raimonda
announces that t'challa has gone to his
ancestors The Black Panther's stats from
an illness that modern medicine even
wakandas can't treat is an obvious
allusion to Bozeman's own death from
colon cancer at the age of 43. it was
both smart screenwriting and
compassionate collaboration that led to
this decision as Kugler explained to The
Hollywood Reporter Bozeman's family
consulted on the film which ensured that
the fun metal product would show the
late actor proper deference other
franchises have had to deal with similar
issues though not to this extent for
example Carrie Fisher's death between
production on The Last Jedi and the rise
of Skywalker deeply affected the final
chapter of the Star Wars saga she was
expected to play a larger role in the
third movie in the sequel trilogy but
her death changed those plans by not
straying too far from the truth wakanda
forever allows us to mourn Bozeman and
t'challa at the same time without
trivializing the tragedy
the primary way we and the characters in
wakanda Forever mourn the loss of the
real actor and the fictional King is
through t'challa's emotional and
elaborate funeral festivities in Captain
America Civil War t'challa talks to
Natasha about how he's processing his
own father's death after the bombing in
Vienna in my culture death
it's not the end
since wakandans believe in an afterlife
and a spiritual realm the sad occasion
of the King's funeral is both an
opportunity to grieve and a celebration
of his life pulling from African
cultural and religious Heritage will
cause his people Gathering Gauzy white
ceremonial clothing there's dancing
singing and mourning there are plenty of
nods to Chadwick boseman's vaunted place
in the MCU as well
during the funeral we see a shot of two
drummers playing in front of a mural of
King t'challa wakandan letters surround
a black and white painting of the Fallen
Black Panther's face production designer
Hannah beachler actually developed a
written language for wakanda in the
first film according to Indie wire from
what we can see some of those characters
are used here to spell out the king
lives and the panther forever with us
the mural gives filmmakers a way to show
t'challa's face without Bozeman's
physical presence and without resorting
to flashbacks too often but it's also a
reference to something that really
happened in the wake of the Beloved
actor's death Disneyland commissioned an
official mural of Chadwick Boseman that
was displayed at Downtown Disney and it
eventually moved to a children's
hospital where it will remain as a
permanent installation other murals
began to pop up around the country to
honor the man who had been a hero and an
inspiration to so many the mural in
wakanda Forever is an acknowledgment of
t'challa's importance to the wakandans
and of Bozeman's importance to multiple
communities
the wakandan alphabet can be spotted
throughout both black panther films in
wakanda Forever Riri Williams is taken
back to the secretive African nation and
sees their Rich culture and advanced
technology for the first time as she's
given a sort of VIP tour the Durham
milage stand guard in front of
rectangular columns which are lit from
within and decorated with wakandan
characters each one contains a word or
phrase and the five that are most
visible during riri's visit spell in
power t'challa our hero and honor
forever it appears the designers added
this detail as an Easter egg and an
extra way to stamp Bozeman's memory onto
the set
that nobody can replace t'challa's king
or his Black Panther in the movie
becomes a meta commentary on the idea
that nobody could really replace
Chadwick Boseman in the role wakanda is
without its protector because Eric
killmonger AKA and jadaka burned the
reserves of the heart-shaped herbs so
that no one could challenge him during
the events of the original film burn it
all
as wakanda forever begins literally no
one can replace t'challa since the
enhanced powers of the Black Panther
aren't available to them without their
vibranium-laced plants Queen ramonda is
acting as Regent sure he seems more
interested in science than politics and
mbaku is content to lead the Jabari and
be an ally of the wakandan crown and
since shuri has given up on the idea of
creating a synthetic heart-shaped herb
everybody else has given up on the idea
of there ever being a black panther
again indeed there isn't one until the
climax of wakanda forever narratively
this works well to give Bozeman his due
and to build anticipation for the moment
when shuri finally takes the mantle
one of the reason Chadwick boseman's
loss hit so hard among moviegoers who
didn't know him personally was because
the actor gave off such a warm authentic
and eminently likable energy he brought
that energy to t'challa who was among
the more stoic characters in the MCU
black panther didn't get quips and gags
like Iron Man Ant-Man Star-Lord or
Doctor Strange he was the mcu's straight
man even more so than Captain America in
stark contrast killmonger his cousin and
antagonist in Black Panther got to chew
the scenery while t'challa remained
Regal and restrained Michael B Jordan
gets to come back in one of the mcu's
most purposeful cameos as killmacher who
didn't make it out of the last movie
alive when shuri enters the ancestral
plane she wants to see her brother or
her mother instead she sees killmacher
who shares the rage she has at having
lost her family it would have been
unrealistic for killmonger a notoriously
confrontational and viciously honest
character to have softened too much
toward his former rival what njidaka has
to say to shuri about her brother is
completely in keeping with his character
he admits that t'challa was a good man
but warned shuri that he was too Noble
for his own good shuri takes this advice
to Heart Waging War against the talocon
until she realizes her name was thirst
for vengeance can only end in Calamity
for both of their Nations
[Music]
after the climactic battle in wakanda
Forever shuri heads to Haiti to burn her
funeral clothes and finally grieve her
brother's passing in peace shots of the
fibers burning are intercut with
breathtaking shots of shuri and profile
beginning to cry when she closes her
eyes we see a montage of her memories of
t'challa made up of Bozeman's highlights
from his four film tenure in the MCU
these clips Crossfade into the end
credits accompanied by Rihanna's new
original song Lift Me Up the lyrics of
which include the repeated phrase keep
me in the warmth of your love when you
depart it's undoubtedly the quietest
calmest and most Earnest ending in MCU
history this symbolic end to shuri's
morning period is also incredibly
cathartic for the audience who's
probably dabbing the tears from their
eyes when the final title card appears
reading dedicated to our friend Chadwick
Boseman it's a beautiful
contribution to Chadwick's Legacy
usually Marvel's mid and end credit
Stingers are reserved for teasing new
projects and making tongue-in-cheek
jokes wakanda forever uses its lone and
longer than usual mid-credits scene to
touchingly and gracefully transition the
Black Panther franchise within a
franchise onto the next leg of its
Journey while shuri's still having a
moment on the beach Nakia walks down to
where she's sitting with a young boy she
introduces him as her son and shuri's
nephew Toussaint as it happens t'challa
prepared Nakia and their secret son for
his death and the family of two has been
staying away from whatever drama will
await the Young Prince when he comes of
age shuri is heartened to find out that
Rwanda got to meet her grandson before
she died then the adorable kid tells his
entry that Toussaint is his Haitian name
but his real name is t'challa this new
and unexpected mid-credits information
is an elegant solution to the problem of
whether or not to cast a new king
t'challa introducing the character's son
allows Bozeman to Remain the sole actor
to portray King t'challa son of t'chaka
while the next Generations t'challa can
eventually become a part of the MCU in
his own right
[Music]